the foreign key constraint keeps the
link between the tables by preventing
invalid data from being inserted into
the foreign key column because the value
has to be one of the values contained in
the table the constraint points to well
what does this mean for testing it means
that we cannot test the weather table
without having the location table
because the foreign key constraint
enforces that the location ID is a valid
ID in the location table it also means
that we have to use the result of an
insert in the location table in order to
insert in the weather table in other
words the weather table cannot be unit
tested independently from the location
table
we are going to be writing a database
test for sunshine which will have to
work with the constraint